let's talk a bit more about setting good
KP is a key performance indicator or KPI
is a measurable value that demonstrates
how effectively a company is achieving
their key business objectives
organizations use KPIs to evaluate their
success at reaching targets as opposed
to metrics would simply demonstrate the
current state of events of a company how
much money they're making how many
customers that they have kpi's clearly
indicate where actions for change should
be taken for example you could set KPIs
to measure increases in customer
satisfaction you could also look at app
installations / whatever days 10 15 30
100 you can also look at the number of
active users after 30 days the important
aspect when selecting KPIs is to ensure
that they're tied to your own business
objectives it's a good idea to be agile
here and to customize your KPIs as you
progress with your startup so take a
minute and think about some of the KPIs
that you might set for your product and
then how might you evaluate whether or
not the KPIs that you've selected are
the right ones use this box to record
your response